I'm really putting now Elvis's on
finding secrets or getting hundred
percent in every mission I think women
just add more time to the game really on
this same time well
you'll just have to stay back and try
and get as many headshots as possible I
look out for glowing eyes yes yes he's
dead and there's another one and another
one my god
gagging off the radioactive sludge or
whatever it is apologies have I blown
into my microphone I'm not really sure
how to avoid that without pop filter I
think it's called which I did not have
unfortunately
yes that takes a lot of the realm
are you there
all right that takes care of those
unexpected as the yellow King I just
shoot as many barrels possible I don't
have to shoot as many zombies good you
may be wondering why in clearing zones
and I'm not in basically it's just less
stressful especially when you're dealing
with demons because whatever they get
right up close and personal it's really
not fun for anyone especially bloom one
guy I don't really know what his name is
always good to be cautious going through
doors
the notion of headshots counteth
shotguns I think it's pretty hard not to
hit someone's head in the shotgun
okay just using this lift to my
advantage
well what's that good God
well there's a lot of people here I
think I'm gonna make my way to the exit
if the lift would go up right now that
would be awesome
look ah a little bit of safety right
yeah I think I think I've got them all
it's getting as much ammunition as
possible I don't really
going around the other side I think if
you kick these barrels yes good that
should have killed another good some
heavy armor up there
I think I'll aim for that think the
switch
didn't see that coming out up I really
should learn this game really does throw
everything in has are you sometimes I'm
more worried about is I'm actually
playing this under medium difficulty
setting and this is quite hard I have no
idea what the hardest difficulty setting
would even try to throw at me
mmm
okay whoever and get this screen amiss
always try to look for more else
especially when there's radioactive goo
about you know not really sure what I'm
when to do with these switches we're
supposed to throw this again okay block
ah no all right I try this one more time
okay
after this if this fails I will just go
exploit their do it
maybe here well that would have been
useful about two minutes ago go well
do you have to press them and I don't
know I don't know let's go exploring
through the blood-soaked corridors so
gruesome ah now this is up that's tough
take care of him reloading always
disrupts the flow of combat it was a
good idea to shoot those barrels a
couple these shotguns need all the
ammunition I can get somebody should use
the rocket launcher here I'm afraid of
damaging myself
lot of dodgy going on here some
successful I had someone successful like
that one just happened there kick in the
face mmm now that cure I can really get
find I just have to use a rocket there
it would have lost my mind if I didn't
there anymore yes there was he ambushed
me
clever girl Oh like a heard another yes
alright
okay this is quite a dangerous room it's
dark and full of people with shotguns
and assault rifles and if I was a
betting man I would say hips and demons
as well and I'm right okay I don't know
where I am I was extremely lucky I
really was
come on just shoot these anyway just for
safety and to light the room up a little
bit it's almost completely pitch black
well I hate myself for that explosion
but it did take out a lot of enemies
with it so then we help me look for HP
so I'm fine it's not on the exit
not before I shoot more demons right he
logged into the face
now are we done
I think we are who is going to take a
brief pause per drink water but even I
need to stay hydrated sometimes okay now
this is hard a straight off the bat
because I'm getting shot for Westbourne
and I seem to be been shooting nonstop
from the word girl so that I'm just
going to run here as I think adores go
driving and she reacts to clear most of
the room for me because I'm lazy
good
focusing on Matt Schulze kick to the
face
not too good for range although they
still are quite accurate more so than I
would be right just make sure they
reload this I can carry as much
ammunition as possible um I have no idea
where you came from
chibs sticking to the wall
lovely so I checked with a minute is
trying to get some keys as much door so
they just locked here
well that's a blue key right
to try walking on that radioactive
slugging it always ends up in a secret I
think it's like go as fast as possible
also take a good run up to it and it's a
cell sphere so that was one effect and
it was also worth it cuz I got salami
album so good what the hell that's me
okay I think I just freed so on oh that
was not in the original game
as meant to be from that video I've got
thermal goggles which don't really seem
to be helping without much although
maybe I can see invisible demons if that
is the case then there will be good it's
going all over that door
looks like a maze
Oh wasn't there when he is now whoa whoa
slightly scary I don't know why I'm
scared because I have a hundred and
seventy four wealth one well flick this
switch what that look most like need
open the door somewhere else but I'm
sure finally he's bloody girls are
wearing off really not useful they don't
open something of it
I figured it'd now bad idea lucky I had
heavy armor okay I'm getting chased by
an invisible thing died right trying to
conserve as much health as possible iam
yes I don't have that K you go okay
where am I supposed to go can't go in
here because that's where I got the blue
key from okay and what's in here
we'll see
we can't shoot him again cuz I set off
the ground or cruelty bonus if I'm cruel
I get awarded health if any of this were
real life I would have unlimited hell
need to find my yellow key it's already
if she said it's always useful I'm
fairly certain I'm missing something
hmm maybe it's back when I was maybe I
rushed through here too too quickly
no I think it might be back on that maze
maybe lose it all back there
ah you're just good and it's the yellow
key and a backpack full of ammunition I
think this is actually upgrading my
capacity and I have more than 50 shop
hotels so hard to thing with those
things
right
now I can go through these doors being
careful not to stumble into too many
enemies
the reloading and brutal doom really
does add another another gameplay
element that wasn't really in the first
one I'm not sure if I like it or not
because it makes the game harder and I'm
lazy I'm almost dead
I'm it's fairly reasonable that I might
die sorry
people are going to try and scrounge as
much health as possible whilst avoiding
enemies just so you know I tried
this is the emergency I spoke of earlier
right okay 60 health that's respectable
I have a little bit of armor to
supplement that so if I'm careful
there's oil good I think I'm back to
fighting strength again
judging by doing guy's face I'm
completely fine now like somebody's blue
over like that
that seems to be a switch unlocks a door
was just tricking those knowing behind
me I have the tendency to get ambushed
almost constantly in this game there was
people down there see I have no idea
where you came from
loads of people in here I can hit that
barrel
invisible demon is abundant now that
would be awesome shooting now let me
have that so close yet so far thank you
ah London 76 health I've never felt
better
alright shut him mid job it was very
satisfied well this has been the
hairiest episode yet I think if it
wasn't for that soul spirit probably
would have died there
anyone comes like a day tomorrow
well helpful I don't need it looks like
they have to go through
well this looks very ominous what cannot
you at the ready
you really made my life a lot easier
that would have been considerably more
difficult if I didn't have it I guess
I'm just lucky no my supposed to get out
of here ah okay good good
won't they come from hmm
liyan
who
always with the invisible demons how
many of them are there
criminy I don't even I never loved
shotgun rounds in my coop today to deal
with this apologies for the stuttering I
just soak and Fuzzle ah oh it's good
oh there had to be more than that it's
the law Wow
that was the hairiest level yet
you